[Music]
on this saturday night la viv under fire
[Music]
fresh attacks on western ukraine as the
u.s president wraps his trip in poland
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power and biden's offer of asylum to
thousands who have fled the war
searching for reconciliation the
catholic church has to acknowledge what
they did to our people we're in rome
with canada's indigenous delegation as
they look for answers from the vatican
plus filling feeds with pressure the
mental health risks men face from social
media and how to avoid them without
ditching the apps and escaping mariupol
there is a constantly sound of the
airplane but you need to go outside
anyways because you cannot survive
without food the dangerous trek to leave
their home city as it crumbles around
them
global national reporting tonight
dallas flex hog
thick black smoke filled the skies of
levive today after powerful explosions
were heard in the western ukrainian city
once thought to be a safe haven for
those fleeing the war
good evening and thank you for joining
us one day after moscow said it would
focus its efforts on ukraine's eastern
donbass region rockets have hit the
country's major western hub the attacks
come as u.s president joe biden wraps up
his trip in neighboring poland we'll
have more on that in a moment but first
jeff semple begins our coverage tonight
from leviev
this isn't exactly the honeymoon yulia
and constantine hordor ben
the couple is setting up their new
apartment in western ukraine after
escaping their home in the east
they're from the donbass region which
has endured some of the worst of this
war and where pro-russian separatists
had already been fighting for years
[Applause]
this was supposed to be the couple's
wedding day but when russia invaded last
month they decided to move up the date
unfortunately i believe this war will
not finish soon so i don't want to wait
anymore as the russian army approached
late last month they went to city hall
and asked to be married immediately but
then air raid sirens sounded and they
all rushed into this basement bomb
shelter
and it's here where the couple said i do
so you got married in a bomb shelter
very unusual place but yeah a nice park
between let's tell a story and we'll
tell our children
when the sirens ended they went back
upstairs and took these wedding photos
no regrets they say though yulia wishes
she'd gotten to wear her wedding dress i
was in unicef hoodie
and eyes race was waiting for me
incremental
they're now hoping to start their new
lives here in the relative safety of
levive far from the front lines russia
said friday it was focusing its mission
on the donbass region on the other side
of the country but it didn't take long
for that claim to prove false just one
day after russia announced it was
refocusing its military campaign in
eastern ukraine we just heard air raid
sirens an explosion and are now seeing
billowing smoke here in levive in
western ukraine levive a humanitarian
hub 70 kilometers from poland was hit at
least four times among the targets a
fuel storage facility a nearby school
was also damaged and at least five
people were hurt
the mayor's press conference providing
those details was cut short by another
air raid silencer
numerous russian strikes were reported
across the country saturday including in
suburbs around the capital kiev i don't
think that any reasonable person right
now would believe anything that
a russian
official or army person would say
even if the eastern donbass region is
indeed russia's new true target it's
clear that doesn't mean the rest of the
country is safe
jeff sample global news live
as the war in ukraine enters its second
month u.s president joe biden was in
neighboring poland wrapping up his
european trip today he pledged to bring
in more ukrainian refugees before taking
aim at russia's president in a fiery
speech to the nation jennifer johnson
has the latest
flanked by his secretaries of state and
defense u.s president joe biden held a
high-stakes meeting with poland's
president in warsaw despite a conflict
with poland over supplying fighter jets
to ukraine biden urged unity in stopping
russia vladimir putin was counting on
being able to divide nato but he hadn't
been able to do it
we've all stayed together
poland which borders ukraine is bearing
the brunt of the refugee crisis over two
million ukrainians have fled to that
country mothers and millions of children
whose lives are in limbo the longer this
goes on the more likely you get
long-term issues which we know long-term
issues are mental health issues they're
development issues
president biden met with dozens of
ukrainians at a soccer stadium pledging
america will take in 100 000 refugees
and calling russian president vladimir
putin a butcher for what he's done to
the ukrainian people each one of those
children said
something in effect say a prayer for my
dad my grandfather or my brother
he's back there fighting
the u.s president ended his four-day
european tour with a speech meant for
the world warning putin not to take his
war outside ukraine's borders don't even
think
about
moving on one single inch of nato
territory
we have a sacred obligation under
article 5 to defend each and every inch
of nato territory
for the full force of our collective
power
biden claims international sanctions are
depleting the russian economy and
weakening the russian military but
ukraine's leaders say they can't wait
for that to take an effect on putin
as they ask every day for more military
firepower to win this unprovoked war
jennifer johnson global news washington
a group of indigenous people from across
the country is making history with a
journey to vatican city for meetings
with pope francis to talk about
reconciliation our neither garcia is in
rome and joins us now with more nathan
what do delegates plan to say to the
pope
dallas when they meet with pope francis
here at the vatican next week indigenous
delegates will be sharing first-hand
accounts of the impact of the
residential school system that forcibly
removed tens of thousands of children
from their homes subjecting many of them
to abuse rape and malnutrition in what
the truth and reconciliation commission
in 2015 called a cultural genocide i
hope the pope realizes in order to move
forward together
the catholic church has to acknowledge
what they did to our people
to our children taylor bain-tacosa is
among 32 knowledge keepers elders
residential school survivors and youth
on a flight to rome this weekend the
delegation of first nations inuit and
may team members all with unique
histories experiences and messages is
set to touch down in italy on sunday
along with six catholic bishops from
across the country the group will travel
about half an hour by bus to a hotel
ahead of the first of four hour long
private meetings with pope francis on
monday this conference room is where
regular media briefings will be held
with delegates during the week
it will be an exhausting and emotional
experience for members some who say they
will not be entering expecting a papal
apology here instead pushing for that to
happen on indigenous land in canada bain
tacosa says without these conversations
no one can move forward but it's
important to acknowledge the many
emotions this trip brings up for
survivors some who are struggling with
the idea of it
a lot of the feelings i mean
come from people who are survivors and
some of them don't feel like that that
they need an apology or that this trip
is worth
anything to them and i just i
acknowledge those feelings
the canadian council of catholic bishops
is responsible for the estimated 350
thousand dollar cost of this delegation
trip it organized using its operating
funds separate from its recently
announced 30 million dollar indigenous
healing and reconciliation fund the
catholic bishops say a papal visit to
canada is imminent but no dates have
been set and there's been no firm
commitment that the visit would include
an apology delegates on their way here
hope that will change after this trip
dallas
neither garcia in rome thanks and there
is some support for survivors a 24-hour
crisis line is available the number is
toll-free you can speak in confidence
that number is 1-800-721-0066
two heavyweights in the conservative
leadership race rallied supporters in
two provinces that could be key in
deciding who becomes the next leader of
the official opposition as david aiken
reports favorite pierre polyeff is
getting some stiffer than expected
competition from patrick brown and john
cheray
thank you very much at a rally just
north of toronto pierre pogliev takes
aim at his rivals how many working folks
can't choose where to go for vacation
because they can't afford a buck 75 a
liter of gas some a price that's going
to rise because of the carbon tax that
justin trudeau has imposed and that
patrick brown and joshua
support pauliev patrick brown and joshua
are at the top right now of a
conservative leadership race already
crowded with nine hopefuls pauliev has
the most support in the conservative
caucus but brown got a big boost last
week when popular conservative mp
michelle rempel garner said she would be
brown's national campaign co-chair brown
also hopes to use the supporters list
that helped him win the ontario
progressive conservative leadership in
2017 to win the federal leadership this
fall
and on friday former ontario premier
mike harris announced his support for
cheray who of course is a former quebec
premier cheray was campaigning saturday
in his old riding of sherbrooke
the focus on ontario and quebec should
surprise no one because this race is
decided on a points system with each and
every riding in the country having a
hundred points up for grabs the
electoral strength of the conservative
party is in the 48 ridings in alberta
and saskatchewan where conservatives
hold just about every seat but it is the
points in the 189 ridings in ontario and
quebec where conservatives hold less
than 50 seats that are crucial for any
conservative leadership campaign dallas
david aiken in ottawa tonight
now pierre paulie have labeled a new
deal between trudeau's liberals and new
democrats a coalition power packed this
week it means the liberals will
prioritize policy issues favored by the
ndp in exchange for the party's support
for more on that and whether the ndp
could pay a price eric sorenson spoke to
ndp leader doug mead singh on the west
block eric
dallas one big question is does the
liberal ndp deal to keep the government
in office for up to three more years
risk making the new democrats
indistinguishable from liberals or worse
invisible
the liberals are shifting left to adopt
ndp policies on drugs and dental care
but our new democrats also shifting
right on the west block leader jagmeet
singh said his party will support an
increase in military spending but stop
short of endorsing the nato spending
target of 2 percent of gdp we believe
that there should be of course uh
increased support for
the the tools that they need as well as
staffing we've seen a drop in personnel
and we ask our military to do lots of
things like going in to help during the
pandemic in seniors homes so we know
that they need help and support and
we're okay with that we think that's the
right thing to do but we do not support
the two percent of nato singh
acknowledges that the party could pay a
price electorally if the liberals as the
governing party can claim credit for ndp
initiatives there may be risks but
there's also incredible opportunities
when we say to canadians why vote for
new democrats
they often see us fighting for them but
they don't see results and people want
to know what's in it for me what are you
going to get me and my family how are
you going to make my life better now we
can say with 25 mps we got people dental
care singh says he's optimistic
canadians will not forget new democrats
but will reward them with more seats in
the next election an election he says he
will absolutely be running in
dallas eric sorenson in ottawa thanks
eric
the gaps in support for veterans coming
up a fatality inquiry in a
murder-suicide exposes where the system
failed a canadian afghan war vet
a fatality inquiry in nova scotia has
uncovered more issues surrounding
domestic violence and treatment for
post-traumatic stress disorder in
military members it stems from the
murder-suicide of lionel desmond his
wife mother and daughter five years ago
ross lord reports
corporal lionel desmond put his life on
the line for canada but testimony at a
provincial fatality inquiry shows
efforts to help him with his
post-traumatic stress disorder fell
short before testimony ended on march 22
the judge in charge of the inquiry
warren zimmer made it clear there are
gaps in policing and support systems be
more concerned with
changes in the system that would
help close those gaps so that things
don't slip through including sharing
information more widely about police
calls for domestic disputes even if they
don't result in charges desmond and his
wife shaina had a troubled marriage
after he left the military there were no
allegations of physical violence but
there were calls to police
inquiry heard nova scotia police had few
training courses on intimate partner
violence because police consultants who
left through attrition were not replaced
his silence
of afghanistan and him not sharing you
know much about afghanistan was enough
to say that
afghanistan done a lot to that man
psychiatrists testified desmond was
preoccupied by thoughts that forced him
to relive traumatic experiences he
endured in afghanistan in 2007. he had
been released from an impatient
psychiatric facility less than five
months earlier seeing six nova scotia
doctors in the following months
a crisis worker who interviewed desmond
and his wife together told the inquiry
she now questions her own approach i
wonder if i had made sure
to have time alone
if anything if any either of them would
have disclosed anything differently or
it took veterans affairs canada six
months to appoint a case manager for
desmond a delay witnesses blamed on
budget cuts
lawyers will make final submissions in
april a final report with
recommendations is expected this fall
ross lord global news
ahead the pressure of social media on
men how mental health issues intensify
with every post
[Music]
foo fighters drummer taylor hawkins has
died at the age of 50. no cause of death
has been revealed and the band is asking
for privacy for hawkins family at this
time
the kova 19 pandemic has seen canadians
spending more time on their phones than
ever before that involves scrolling
through social media time and time again
as jamie morocco explains it's a habit
that can lead to some major mental
health challenges
scrolling through social media may be a
good distraction for abdullah barez but
it doesn't make him feel great about
himself with every photo he says comes
pressure to be better eat cleaner and
hit the gym harder it kind of gives you
this unrealistic
i guess ideal of what a man should be
though not officially diagnosed perez
described his feelings of insecurity as
body dysmorphia a mental health
condition resulting in an obsessive
negative perception about one's body
research shows in men body image issues
can be linked to anxiety depression and
even suicidal thoughts or behavior and
experts say social media is making the
problem worse
a man might compare himself or his own
body to what he's seeing on social media
which those images are
incredibly unattainable uh filtered
photoshopped could be edited so the
ideal body type becomes increasingly
unrealistic
and exaggerated at the university of
toronto kyle ganson is studying eating
disorders muscle building behaviors and
body image he says almost all of the
people he has interviewed have
referenced influencers or youtubers as
inspiration
these sort of platforms influence their
body image and the desires to change
their body in specific ways once you
start following one bodybuilder or like
a post about dieting an app's algorithms
can fill up a feed with more of the same
marketing expert jenna drenton says
these companies are aware and are
implementing changes
certain hashtags are banned however
consumers are incredibly savvy and find
ways to create different hashtags the
onus then falls largely onto creators to
put out healthy safe and unedited
content and on consumers to educate
themselves and filter who they follow
perhaps easier said than done when any
type of suggested content can still make
it onto one's home page jamie morrocker
global news toronto
next escaping mariupol cut off from the
world and scrounging for food
how a pair of sisters found their way to
safety
[Music]
even if russia pulls back on its goals
in this war one city it may still try to
take is mariupol holding the port city
would give a land corridor between
crimea and the donbass region but
despite constant shelling for the past
month only about half its residents have
left mike armstrong spoke with two
sisters who have now reached safety
every day it was worse and worse they
are two sisters sharing one story about
leaving home we couldn't stay there
this is what they left behind mariupol
basically being reduced to rubble and
cut off without phones or internet twin
sisters anastasia and hannah rechkina
didn't understand what was going on they
thought that maybe if no one is safe
comes to save us maybe the world just
doesn't know about the situation
that's how we saw it
now on the day of the invasion the
sisters say at first they didn't realize
it was happening their city was fought
over in 2014 when russia-backed rebels
took over parts of the donbass region in
the eight years since it was close
enough to the front lines they could
sometimes hear fighting off in the
distance
the explosions when the invasion started
were closer i said mom putin attacked a
maripo now
and then we realized that
it's a real war it's not what we used to
in mariupol
what came next was weeks of scrounging
and hunger in the first days they
rationed the little they had then they
scavenged searching friends homes and
apartments people who'd left looking for
anything we were checking
every shelf if they have something and i
was happy oh my god i found the candle
oh my god i found the
rice or i found something else
the challenge after that was what to do
with what they found without gas or
electricity everything had to be cooked
over a fire out in the open
exposed when you need to go outside to
cook food then there is shelling and you
need to hide there is a constantly sound
of the airplane but you need to go
outside anyways because you cannot
survive without food
the sisters were able to escape they're
still in ukraine but at least safer
their ride out of mariupol was a
stranger who agreed to take their group
just somewhere
i don't know where we where are we going
i don't know how
how much time it will take but i was
happy that i'm i'm in a car i'm
i'm all we are all always with
our family and
that's all i wanted
now there is one thing the sisters feel
guilty about locking the door to their
apartment there isn't much but there is
some food left food they say their
neighbors likely need
desperately
mike armstrong global news krakow poland
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm dallas flex
tonight we leave you in kelowna bc where
members of the local ukrainian community
are rolling up their sleeves preparing
traditional ukrainian treats they're
raising money for medical supplies and
food to help families affected by the
war thanks for watching take care